[Music]
i usually don't like to introduce
someone based on their resume
arthur brooks has written 12 books he's
the former president of the aei and he
teaches at harvard business school he is
a pretty smart and well accomplished guy
so what would we talk about you ask
well it's one thing to accomplish a lot
it's another thing
to be happy
and this is what arthur is thinking
about these days
how can we be happy
in the work that we do
this
is a bit of optimism
here's the trouble i have talking to you
and i think this every time we talk i
love you to death but i always feel a
little dumb
[Laughter]
well i just always feel a little
pretentious
that's worse simon that's worse you're
so smart and so well-read
i love the idea of books and people have
a big
misperception of me which is since i was
a kid i've struggled to read
because undiagnosed adhd when i was
younger so i couldn't focus
a lot of people give me all this credit
for reading all these books and assume
that i'm extremely well read and i i i
like to joke that i've written more
books than i've read
but you harvest material effectively
which is really the skill of serious
non-fiction learning how to learn very
very quickly without being bogged down
in verbiage i think this is something we
don't teach our kids and again i was
very very fortunate that when i was
pretty young i learned how i learned
once i got to college i took classes
that amplified how i learned not
amplified my weaknesses so for example i
avoided classes that relied heavily on
the necessity to read texts i took
classes with very very good professors
who are extremely good at explaining
things that i could go after class and
talk to them about it and i had to go to
every class i couldn't skip classes and
read the text
and so i did okay but we don't teach
kids
how they learn no that's absolutely true
absolutely true i was very lucky that i
learned this and i learned that i
learned from listening and so
a lot of what i know and all my
retention comes from talking to people
you're an auditory learner one of my
sons is a reading learner as a visual
learner one of my sons is an auditory
learner and the auditory learner was
diagnosed with dyslexia and adhd and all
that but he can retain anything that you
tell him
but you have to tell it to him the truth
of the matter is that my son who you
know diagnosed as adhd and dyslexic
those are precisely the qualities that
make him an outstanding us marine yeah
you know the truth of the matter is that
he sees things in a different way than
the rest he's able to solve problems
especially kinetically and in real time
he's a great marine he's a squad leader
he's flourishing he loves his job it's
fun he gets to blow stuff up and jump
out of helicopters and and when it comes
down to it he has to do dangerous things
too and even risk his life which is is
what he wants to do and it you know
somebody who's like you know let me go
and look on the internet about the odds
of dying under these circumstances and
let me think about let me get a book let
me get a book on how to be a good marine
it's not going to be a good marine i'm
so proud of him for becoming a man fully
alive yeah and and not only getting
around what we would call a learning
disability but flourishing because
of the way that he's wired and doing
something that frankly
i couldn't do like your son i was
diagnosed only as an adult with adhd it
is my superpower and one of the problems
with modern medicine is we study
especially in psychology we study broken
but we don't study what works and so the
whole happiness movement is great
because we're studying what works i
lament the fact that we call it
the attention deficit disorder we tell a
child you have a deficit and a disorder
me and everybody who else who has add
adhd we have hyper focus and i prefer to
say i have hyper focus and occasionally
i'm extremely distractible and struggle
to get my work done but when i have
focus my mind is crystal clear and
adrenaline helps me which is why i'm
good on stage because it's it's exciting
and the adrenaline pumps when i go on
stage and i i'm lucid i wish we would
tell children they have a superpower
that comes with a liability rather than
you have a liability and we never tell
them about the superpower
yeah for sure and you know there are
all kinds of ways to exploit the unique
advantages of people who learn in these
different ways whose brains are wired in
these ways this is not some evolutionary
pro glitch this is not a an an oversight
by mother nature on the contrary there's
a reason that so many people learn in
this particular way because there's a
genetic advantage there's an
evolutionary set of benefits that
actually comes from this but we have
decided because we treat people like
cogs in a machine
and you know we march everybody through
these you know routinized syndicalized
school things where everybody's crazily
the same age year after year after year
so we can't learn from people with
different levels of experience right and
then we set them up like we're stamping
out widgets in a factory so everybody's
got to learn the same way and by the way
it's very convenient if they sit quietly
you know sitting quietly is wonderful
for teachers it's just really bad for
students as it turns out and if we were
a little bit more creative and we cared
more about children
we would have an education system that's
more tailored to the advantages and as
such we'd be a much richer society
there's other examples that we dislike
but they're really important to keep in
mind and a classic case of this is the
way that we treat clinical depression
and anxiety
you know we have a tendency to say that
this is the broken brain it's just a big
mistake and again there's tons of
suffering and you don't want to have
your boat overturned by suffering and
you know you have to have things treated
from time to time such that you can
function as a human being without
complete misery but the truth of the
matter is if you like any any fair
reading literature shows that that
people who have some
dysthemic tendency some
chronically low mood they're better
decision makers they tend to be more
creative they have a better grasp on
reality they make fewer mistakes in
their decision making and so the point
is the most important thing that we can
do is not to regret who we are and to
remediate everything about us but to
understand ourselves because we have
unique power
i'm going to change tax on you i know
the answer this question so it's
rhetorical and it's designed to spur
conversation
[Laughter]
so you're teaching now do you like
teaching
it's interesting you know i
university teaching is
it's the family business it's the family
business my great my grandfather my
father i mean this is something i grew
up on a college campus when i was 19 i
got myself tossed out of college i mean
i got tossed out of the california
institute of the arts i'm like the first
person in the history to get tossed out
of that place right you have to work
hard
i didn't go to college till i was 30 and
the whole thing was like i'm never going
into academia and then i woke up like
somebody
slipped me a mickey and i woke up as a
college professor and it's turned out to
be great it turned out to be as great as
my dad and grandfather told me what have
you learned
as a teacher
i've learned how other people learn
which is the most important thing that i
see every day getting back to the early
part of our conversation one of the big
problems at universities and some people
had pretty mediocre or unrewarding
experiences as college students
especially i mean think of your
economics 101 class why was that
unrewarding because the teacher would
come in and she or he would say um would
i have a model and write the model on
the chalkboard and make you learn the
model and then give you a couple of
examples and move on and the examples
would be you know the cheese industry or
the widgets industry or something really
boring you didn't quite get it didn't
quite care and and the reason for that
is that about five percent of learners
they tend to learn
deductively which is to say that they
get a model and then they expose it to
data but 95 of people learn inductively
they notice all kinds of stuff around
them and then they try to look for
patterns the biggest revelatory
experience for me is being kind of an
academic but that most of my students
are inductive i turn around the entire
way that i explain things and so i'll
say did you ever notice isn't it weird
how people behave did you ever feel and
now i teach happiness i mean i teach
this big happiness class at harvard
business school it's perfect for
inductive learning so the first 20
minutes of the lecture will be a bunch
of experiences that people have and
asking people if they've ever felt this
and that and the other thing and then
i'll say
well it turns out there are 50 academic
journal articles explaining what's going
on with the neural substrates of the
brain and actually what the bias is and
and the social scientists have weighed
in and by the way aristotle was talking
about it in this way and by that point
they're locked man they're locked
because they're starting to understand
themselves but only when they can see
themselves at the beginning so that's
the most interesting thing for me from
teaching is that i have learned how
people learn so good and so i can teach
to people in a way that is an expression
of my love
that is so good that is so good and the
key point is also
that the algorithm for getting happier
is actually relatively simple i mean the
biggest mistake people make is they wish
that they were happier but they don't
work for it
the second thing is that they learn
about it but they don't apply it and
then the third part is that they don't
share it and so the way to learn
happiness to become happier
i can't say you'll be happy because you
know there are limits for each one of us
but you can be happier is number one
work for it by learning about it you
know use your brain to learn about human
happiness number two apply it practice
it in your life you know just as you
wouldn't you know try to learn golf from
a book
you got to actually go out there and
play golf not that i do and the third is
the most beautiful at all of all which
is that you can only get it when you
give it and and that's where the
leadership comes in happiness and
leadership is the study the science and
practice of happiness in your life and
the way that you cement it into your own
life by sharing it with your sisters and
brothers and leaders have a unique
opportunity to do that i've seen you so
compellingly talk about this to talk
about how leaders have this this gift
this gift which is not just you know
telling people barking orders down the
hall it's this gift of actually being a
teacher of things that matter in
people's lives by embedding core values
into your message into your leadership
journey what a gift that is and leaders
get to do that and good teachers people
who like teaching are good leaders
because they want to see those people
around them do well they want to see
them excel they're cheering for them
rather than as you said the command and
control do as i say or you could say
that great leaders are great teachers
too you could say the great leaders they
they're they're pedagogical you know
they're they're pure crystallized
intelligence and great leaders never
consider themselves experts in
leadership they all consider themselves
students of leadership and you and i
who've you know we've both met some
remarkable leaders over the course of
our careers and they're insatiably
curious about leadership they read books
they read articles they want to talk
about it like they're really
accomplished people and they want to
talk about the topic all the time yeah
for sure they can be the chief executive
officer of the general motors and if you
tell them some interesting insight that
occurred to you they'll be like oh wait
a second i want to write that down i
don't want to forget that
that's important because that means
they're learning they don't want things
to escape them they want to make a big
idea more than just a sensation they
want to make it metacognitive so they
can use it
today
is february 15th
and your new book comes out today
yes indeed yes indeed february 15th and
after valentine's day is
strength to strength day
prank the strength day and you read it
you read it a long time ago you blurbed
the book my blurbers were simon cynic
and the dalai lama so from now on i'm
going to call you your holiness simon
cynic
holy cow you got the dalai lama to blurb
a book
it was a very calm blurb i have to say
arthur brooks has written a book that
shall help people
hey man it's the dalai lama how did you
get to know the dalai lama i put
together a list this is about 10 years
ago when i was still president of aei
except for our listeners that's a think
tank in washington dc that i led for a
long time and i made a list of the
people that i thought that i needed to
know
so that i could be better at what i did
and furthermore that people would find
unusual alliances one of the great
aspects of effective leadership is going
where you're not invited and saying
things that people don't expect in a
spirit of love i made a list of people
and i put the dalai lama on it i taught
you know publishing the new york times
places that the president of the
american enterprise institute would not
ordinarily show up but then i had to
figure out how to execute on that i
figured out who actually worked with his
holiness in the united states
and then i
secured an opportunity to get an hour of
his time at his monastery in dharamsala
in the himalayan foothills and then i
went there
at that point there was no flights from
you know the closest city was a seven
hour drive and i almost hit a goat on
the way i mean it was just harrowing up
the mountain and i sat for an hour with
this holiness and we talked and it was
this
for me a magical connection and over the
last 10 years since that first meeting
we've worked together we've written
together we've i've interviewed him he
was the first guest speaker in my
harvard class last january which was
me and my harvard students and 14
million people on live webinar
which was a beautiful experience i have
to say he has taught me so much about
what it means to be
a full a full human on the earth i have
to say i love him he's been a mentor and
teacher to me and a really really
treasured relationship what's one thing
that you've learned from him that we can
internalize and implement reasonably
easily to take one step towards that
better human being space let me give an
example this is something i talk about
this new book strength to strength and
it's about the satisfaction problem in
the hedonic treadmill you know this like
run run run run run and your brain is
telling you if you get there and you hit
the goal and you know you'll get the
reward and it will endure for the rest
of your life notwithstanding mick
jagger's injunction that he can't get no
satisfaction etc well the dalai lama
tells us how we can solve that problem
and it's basically this he says to get
stable and steady happiness we need to
stop
having what we want and we need to start
wanting what we have
and what that means basically is this
how to implement this in in practical
terms is the following
we think that satisfaction is a function
of getting what we want of having things
you know all if i have that job if i
have that spouse if i have that
relationship if i have that success if i
have that money then i'll be satisfied
and and no you won't the real way to
understand this is that to remember that
your satisfaction is not a function of
what you have
your satisfaction is what you have
divided by what you want it's a fraction
and the wants are the denominator of
your happiness fraction and if you don't
know about your wants if you don't have
a if you only have a halves management
strategy you're doomed
but if you have a wants management
strategy you can decrease the
denominator and there are ways to do
that
you're haves divided by your wants the
number goes up if you have fewer ones
and have more halves so it's not i wish
i had the new
it's i love the thing i've got
or
i'm going to break my attachment to
something that i'm craving and so here's
what i recommend to lower the
denominator of your satisfaction
equation which is halves divided by
wants how do you manage your wants
we've learned
forever that we got to have a bucket
list you know it's on your birthday
write down your cravings and desires and
attachments and this is what's going to
fuel your ambitions and it's going to
make you more successful you're going to
climb the ladder et cetera et cetera et
cetera the bucket list is a
metastatically terrible idea for your
satisfaction what you need is a reverse
bucket list and the reverse bucket list
is where you do make a list of your
cravings and your desires and your
attachments absolutely on your birthday
and then
put your hand in that bucket and take a
handful of those things and say i am no
longer chained to this attachment if i
get it fine but i'm no longer going to
consider my success a function of the
car and the relationship and the success
the outward success and the admiration
of others and the money and the power
and the pleasure and the fame huh
goodbye and saying i am the master of my
own desires is this reverse bucket list
is a positive act of rebellion against
your wants it seems like western society
is hell-bent on the opposite
what is the first step that we can take
to sort of
operate independently within the system
it's all fine and good to talk about you
know the reverse bucket list but the
pressures upon us are extreme you know
that really famous book called atomic
habits by james clear
he makes a very good point on how to do
this which is he says stop paying so
much attention to goals and start paying
more attention to systems
i mean systems are what they do is they
make it possible for you to be effective
day to day and to be more mindful of
what you're doing your systems should be
putting your priorities in order one of
the things that we find about the
happiest people is that they're really
focusing on four things
their faith their life philosophy
their family life their friendships
their deep friendships and work that is
meaningful in so far that they feel
they're earning their success and
serving other people those are the four
things you know if you're gonna have a
bucket list make it those four things
but to to do those four things it's not
about worldly goals it's about proper
systems and so what i recommend to my
students is that we do it we have a
little exercise called intention without
attachment
where you basically say okay where do i
want to be in my life in you know my my
in my family life in my faith life and
my friendships and my work 10 years from
now just kind of
describe it 10 years from now okay now
what do i need to be doing in five years
to be on track for that what do i need
to be in in one year what about one
month what about one week okay
what do i need to do today what are the
systems i need in place today and then
live in the daytime compartment
that is intention without attachment
with a focus on systems and a
mindfulness that can bring you true and
and enduring
enjoyment this is finite infinite
thinking right the goals are finite and
systems are infinite this is your newest
book speaking of newest books what was
the motivation for strength to strength
i was on an airplane
eight years ago
and it was very dark on the plane eleven
o'clock at night or something and i
heard a couple behind me talking it was
an elderly couple i could tell their
voices and i assumed it was a married
couple man and a woman i don't know but
i assumed so
and i couldn't quite make out the
husband's words but i heard the wife
saying oh don't say it would be better
if you were dead
i'm like whoa man that's heavy and then
i hear him bumble bumble bumble and she
says
it's not true that nobody cares about
you anymore that nobody respects you
that nobody even knows who you are
anymore and this goes on for like 20
minutes and and i get in my head this
picture of this guy he's probably
disappointed with his life he didn't get
the education that he wanted and didn't
get the promotions and the jobs or start
the companies and now he's kind of put
out to pasture and he's disappointed
the lights go on when we landed dulles
and i'm
curious enough that i want to get a look
and it turns out to be one of the most
famous men in the world this is not
controversial he's beloved for his
achievements that happened a long time
ago and this is blowing my mind and
i'm just sort of thinking about this you
know as a social scientist this is
interesting and and it has this human
pathos and as we're leaving the plane
the pilot spots him looks right through
me like a pane of glass and looks to the
guy behind me now
who's a hero
and says
sir you've been my hero since i was a
little boy
and i turned around and he's
beaming
and i ask myself which is the real guy
this one or 20 minutes ago and then i
had a selfish thought
how can i be that guy now and not that
guy 20 minutes from now look i'm not
going to be a great world famous hero
this guy's a much bigger deal than i am
or ever will be but i'm trying to do a
lot with my life and so are you and the
fact that people are listening to this
podcast means so are they
they're trying to get the
most juice that they can get from this
piece of fruit we call life how can you
if you do all that striving and
struggling and and working and
how can you make sure you're
on the upper branch of happiness and not
going back down again because it turns
out
the data are very clear that around age
70 the population breaks up into two
groups
one group keeps getting happier all the
way to the end and the other group which
is about half start decreasing in
happiness
all the way to the end i want to be on
the upper branch i don't want to be like
the guy who did a lot with his life and
i was disappointed because it all passed
him by and this book is about what each
person can do at no matter how old they
are whether they're 20 or 50 or
what they can actually do with their
life to give them the biggest fighting
chance to be on the upper branch
and the second half of their lives and i
found the 10 big lessons starting with
the dalai lama but also looking at the
the most cutting edge neuroscience that
can give us the best shot at getting
that i think simon i think
i think i figured it out how different
do you feel from before the book
it's fundamental it's the biggest set of
changes i've ever made in my life and
i'll give an example when i was doing
this i was the chief executive of a
think tank in washington dc um
it was a very high pressure very high
motivation job that got a lot of
attention
and
i saw
that it was good as far as it was going
to be but that it wasn't going to last
and part of it was because there's a
change in the kind of intelligence that
we have as we move from our 40s to our
50s into our 60s that goes from this
fluid intelligence to crystallized
intelligence and crystallized
intelligence rewards the ability to use
ideas put them together to share them
with others much much more so
than what it takes to do what i was
doing as a think tank boss and so
literally on the basis of this research
i quit my job
nobody quits those jobs i quit my job
because i knew what was coming and i
knew what i was going to be good at and
i knew that my gifts were going to be
better served by doing what i do now i
remember talking to you when you decided
to quit and you told me confidentially
that it was going to happen because it
wasn't public knowledge yet and i was
cheering you on
but i had no idea that you were in the
middle of this journaling that led you
to this wonderful insight this wonderful
conclusion to move on for your own
happiness yeah for to remodel my life
and to remodel it in a particular way
that loads on
the particular skills that people have
in their 50s 60s and 70s and they can
even stay high in their 80s 90s but
they're different than the skills that
people have and the natural abilities
people have in their 20s and 30s the
innovative capacity the tirelessness on
a particular single task that you know
people have and then they want to keep
that they want to be a big star they
want to be the star lawyer they want to
be the you know the startup entrepreneur
or something in their 50s and 60s and
wonder why it's coming harder and so
there's a bunch of things that we can do
to understand ourselves to cultivate
that wisdom that that particular
crystallized intelligence and to turn it
into a new vocation that's other focused
charles darwin if you had a three
greatest scientist of all time charles
darwin would be on your list it's just
you know he's inflecting in the way that
he understood the natural world as a
biologist and zoologist botanist and he
became a super big star all over europe
when he was in his 20s because he did
this five-year voyage starting when he's
22 as the naturalist on the beagle which
is this sailing ship around the world
and it was there that he collected
samples of all different parts of the
natural world animals and plants
and he also came up with his theory of
evolution
his theory of natural selection he
developed these ideas over the next 30
years of his career and he was the most
innovative guy he was the king of the
mambo when it came to science all over
europe celebrate rich
famous
and then his innovative capacity just
screeched to a halt it just stopped
because he hit a limit in what he could
understand mathematically and it turns
out that the science had gotten to a
point where you needed much more complex
mathematics and statistics to make the
next step in thinking he published like
11 more books but they're all derivative
and duplicative and he felt like kind of
a failure and died
a hero
but disappointed in his own capacity he
was you know he was on the treadmill and
then he got thrown off the back of the
treadmill like some hilarious internet
meme
now somebody did it right was johan
sebastian bach the greatest composer
ever lived he was the
innovative creator of the high baroque
par excellence all the way through his
20s and 30s super famous you know
commissions from the greatest royalty
etc etc but then something happened he
had a lot of kids
he had 20 children as a matter of fact
and his third son carl phillip emmanuel
bach created a new style of music not
the high baroque it was called the
classical style of music
it became all the rage all across europe
and it eclipsed his father his father
was like writing the equivalent of disco
at that point nobody wanted to hear it
and so the father then decided that he
was simply going to spend the rest of
his life as a master teacher
of the forums and he was he spent the
the rest of his life writing a textbook
that was an example of the high birth
because he thought yeah maybe sometime
in the future somebody's going to want
to know about this stuff that used to be
popular it was called the art of fugue
the coonster fuga he was in the middle
of it
and and he stops in the middle of a
measure and it's written on the score in
the hand of carl phillip emmanuel bach
the son who eclipsed him at this point
the composer put down his pen and died
strong finish and he was beloved and he
was happy and he was surrounded by
family and his students what he was
doing is he was taking the greatest that
had been thought and said
and he was putting it together in the
service of others as the master teacher
bach moved off his fluid intelligence
curve to his crystallized intelligence
curve and cultivated his relationships
and his faith and his love and he was
successful and happy in a brand new way
by remodeling his life
i hope young people read this as well
not just people who are in middle age
who are going through this
because i think it sets up expectations
in a recipe for what's the life by
design not believing that the wonderful
disney ride that we're on now lasts and
i've seen this in a couple of friends
which they again wildly successful and
famous in the past
and other people have replaced them in
their disciplines it's the normal course
and they keep talking about what they
did
and what they're doing is an attempt to
recreate what they did
right and i think and this is not just
for people who are wildly successful you
know somebody has one success and we see
this in companies all the time i'm gonna
keep doing that thing because it worked
once it's probably gonna keep working
and i think this is sort of the great
insight here which is
no matter how how much happiness or
about success or the thing that you want
you get all of those things are
temporary every single one of those to
see those and accept those as temporary
absolutely and you know the interesting
thing is also
this period when you are remodeling your
life is something that people well first
they don't know that they can have a
transition but part of it is this fear
this fear of letting things go and and
it takes practice by the way i mean the
idea of taking your career down to the
studs and rebuilding it when you have a
really really good career i mean trust
me man it is it's tricky and you're
going to be lonely you're going to be
insecure and people are not going to
return your calls and you know
politicians that you thought were your
friends it turns out that you're not
real friends you're deal friends you
know this is just the way it works but
there's a key insight about transitions
and this is in the book too
there's a guy named bruce feiler who
wrote a really nice book about his life
is in the transitions and and that's
what social psychologists call
liminality liminality is the time
between two things and it has a
particular
disconsolate feeling i mean it's scary
it's disconcerting but at the same time
it's incredibly fertile and it reminds
me when i was a kid i used to like to
fish and i remember the first time i
went fishing in the ocean i grew up on
the west coast i'm from i'm from seattle
but i was on the oregon coast i went out
fishing on the rocks first time i ever
tried it and i was catching nothing for
two hours and this whizzened old mariner
from you know the town comes up and says
hey kid are you catching anything i'm
like
no is he getting any bites and i said no
he says because you're doing it wrong
and i said what what what am i doing
wrong he said you can only catch fish
during the falling tide now the falling
tide is the time when the tide is going
out really fast i said well
no fish right he said no no no in a
falling tide it looks like everything's
going out but the bait fish and the
plankton are stirred up so the game fish
are going crazy you'll see is it's he
looked at his watch like 28 minutes
later we throw our lines in and we're
pulling him out one after another i mean
it's unbelievable and afterward you know
we're sitting on the rocks exhausted and
he you know he's he lights a cigarette
and he's looking all philosophical and
he says hey kid you know
during a falling tide you can only make
one mistake fishing and i said what is
it he said
not having your line in the water
and that's true for life man i mean
the falling tide it looks like it's
terrible nobody wants the falling tide
the tide's going out this is the end it
was so good
the falling tide it looks like a period
of loss and what it is is
the game fish are waiting for you
get your line in the water when you're
most uncomfortable when you've lost the
most when you feel like the best days
are passed that's your chance that's
when you need to jump on it because
that's when magic can happen
arthur brooks
uh i could talk to you for hours
you are pure magic i stand by what i
said at the beginning of this
conversation which is i've never had a
conversation with you where i didn't
learn something or have a new
perspective my mind right now is firing
off you have so much original thought
and i have learned so much from this
conversation
let's just do this on a regular basis
let's do it man i love it i love every
chance to talk to just gives me more of
an excuse to hang out with my old friend
simon you're fantastic and for those who
want to learn more pick up strength to
strength available at find bookstores
everywhere and some not so fine ones as
well
i meant to all the disreputable
bookstores too
arthur brooks you're the best thank you
so so much thank you brother
[Music]
if you enjoyed this podcast and would
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then take care of yourself
take care of each other